the amount of solid plastic waste
produced since the 1950s that has not
been burned or recycled as around four
point nine billion tons this could all
have been dumped into a 70 meter deep
landfill the size of Manhattan while
much of it has indeed ended up in
landfill around the world far too much
of it has found its way into the natural
environment with around 10 million tons
a year ending up in the ocean over half
of all plastic is used just once and
then thrown away taking hundreds of
years to decompose apart from the
perception that plastic waste is ugly
and unnatural it has also been known to
harm marine animals and exposed to salt
water and sunlight it can fragment into
micro plastics which some people fear
can poison sea life and humans who
subsequently consume it but is it as big
an environmental problem as the plastic
panic across the rich world suggests
plastics account for just 10 percent of
the 1.3 billion tons of waste produced
globally every year air pollution is
blamed for 7 million deaths per year
worldwide ocean acidification the result
of manmade carbon dioxide emissions it's
disastrous for coral reefs and many
other forms of sea life in any case
efforts are being made to improve the
situation or at least lessen the impact
of plastic in 2008 Rwanda introduced
strict laws banning plastic bags and
many countries have since followed with
similar initiatives in December 2017 193
countries committed to a UN plan to stop
plastic waste entering the ocean to
eliminate plastic waste reaching the
natural environment it must first be
collected in developed countries
virtually all of it is but five
countries in Asia are dumping more
plastic into the oceans than the rest of
the world combined if the world wants to
tackle plastic pollution then it should
first concentrate its efforts on the
biggest culprits in Southeast Asia until
it does all other efforts will be a
walk to the ocean
you